[Music]
i'm really excited to show you how app
sheet uses
intent aware ai to help quickly automate
business processes
timely order processing is key to any
business but
it frequently involves various systems
manual steps
and waiting for approvals app sheet
automation helps
solve this by enabling anyone on the
team
to quickly and intelligently automate a
process
let's look at the platform the ai power
platform
anticipates your automation requirements
provides
intelligent suggestions and auto
constructs actions
based on user intent it's super easy to
create a new automation
process steps can be described in plain
english starting to type approval
prompts contextual suggestions steps can
be quickly added
to model your business process and
details can be added later
or picked for you let's fast forward to
the last step in the process
let's add a final step to send the
invoice
to the customer the platform auto
generates the invoice highlights
possible recipients
and even autofills relevant details for
you
great we are done building our process
now let's see this automation
in action as a new order gets added in
salesforce
our process is triggered since it's a
high value order
it's sent to the manager for approval
the manager gets the push notification
on the device the order details are
reviewed
and approved by the manager instantly
from the approvals app
rich approval applications can be built
in minutes using app sheet
the order is then routed to the
warehouse for fulfillment
and the ops team gets notified via
google chat
finally an invoice for this order is
automatically emailed
to the customer automating your business
processes
made easy app sheet automation brings
together
the power of ai and no code in a unified
platform for building rich apps and
powerful automations
within minutes so you can innovate
faster